matt gates isn't the only republican in
trouble in possible trouble
uh on the senate side of the capitol
rand paul
this headline from the washington post
unsurprising headline might i add rand
paul discloses 16 months late that his
wife bought stock in company behind
covid treatment
listen
senators and congress people
i don't know that we should uh exclude
them from investments like stock trading
i don't know
it's tough
i think to say one way or the other
uh definitively it's a there needs to be
more options on the table and looked at
as far as what we should do to curb the
kind of self-dealing
insider trading
benefit from the intelligence that they
have uh and i don't mean intelligence
like brains i mean like intel on the
ground i mean they are they are behind
the scenes able to know things that are
coming down especially related to our
current health crisis
knowing what is happening getting
briefings top secret and otherwise
they're in the know and if they use that
information to enrich themselves
they're at an advantage
and an advantage
that isn't baked into the job
you don't run for congress and represent
a constituency in order that you become
rich
rand paul
mr noble warrior of truth
mr
liberty
that's not what you're there for reading
from the article senator rand paul
revealed wednesday that his wife bought
stock in gilead sciences which makes an
anti-viral drug used to tweet covet 19
on february 26 2020.
what a coincidence
what a shocking coincidence that on
february 26 2020
they bought the stock
and this was before the threat from the
coronavirus was fully understood by the
public and before
it was classified as a pandemic by the
world health organization
the disclosure in a filing with the
senate
came 16 months
after the 45-day reporting deadline set
forth in the stock act which is designed
to combat insider training so there are
regulations there are rules there are
stipulation there are there are rules
that he has stipulated to
that he is bound by
afford after you trade you have 45 days
to report it
for ethics controls
and just so the public knows what's
going on
and he waited 16 months
after
the 45-day limit
experts in corporate and securities law
said the investment and especially the
delayed reporting of it undermined trust
in government and raised questions about
whether the kentucky republicans family
had sought to profit
from non-public information about the
looming health emergency and plans by
the u s government to combat it several
senators sold large amounts of stocks in
january or february of last year
prompting a handful of insider trading
probes most of those investigations
concluded in the spring of 2020
according to notifications from the
justice department to lawmakers under
scrutiny remember kelly leffler
barr from north carolina
all of this
not good
they are trying to enrich themselves
with the knowledge that they have from
their elected office
self-dealing in the age of trump
seems like anything goes
the senator ought to have an explanation
for the trade and more importantly why
it took him almost a year and a half to
discover it from his wife said james d
cox a professor of law at duke
university
kelsey cooper a spokeswoman for paul
said the senator completed a reporting
form for his wife's investment last year
but learned only recently while
preparing an annual disclosure that the
form had not been transmitted
that's a that's a very technical way of
saying oh yeah we didn't send it
we didn't email that we didn't include
that
it wasn't transmitted hmm he sought
guidance from the senate ethics
committee she said and filed the
supplemental report wednesday along with
the annual disclosure which was due in
may and submitted three months late
she also said paul's wife kelly an
author and former communications
consultant lost money on the investment
which she made with her own earnings
the purchase was of between
one thousand and fifteen thousand
dollars of stock in gilead which makes
the anti-viral drug known as ezram
desophere
the company's stock was worth 74 listen
to this seriously listen to this
this is how they're saying they lost
money
the company stock was worth seventy four
dollars and seventy cents per share on
the day of the purchase and rose above
eighty dollars in march it has since
since though now that they're reporting
that they've lost money on it now
they're reporting that they bought it
it has since fluctuated and was worth
69.84 on the day of paul's disclosure
more than a year later
so because they made a bad investment
had they had they had they this stock
skyrocketed and they made all kinds of
money who knows what would have taken
place who knows how long we would have
had to wait or if we would have ever
found out at all
disgusting unethical immoral use of his
office to enrich himself he and his wife
no good
no
good and it is patterned and practiced
for republicans to skirt the rules while
screaming from the rooftops about
propriety
and morality and family values and truth
and justice and the
american way
unacceptable senator paul
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video